hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome back to let's play drunk
minecraft
i'm here with still fill still filled
oval sorry okay and his papi jr. and Bob
wait yeah yeah we'd still banging his
girlfriend still bangin down like that
guys got you know you cut a man oh man
he says it ah I probably should make fun
of them like that but anyway yeah so we
are here in the depths of hell I'm
guessing Oh God
Bob Bob there are zombies literally in
all directions oh there's a door over
there near the soul cent house I think
we should make a run for it let's go
they're coming this way before you go go
go go go go go the door was aiming it
mom hurry up hurry up oh god wait is it
closed in Oh hop up uh-oh
there are chests in all of these
buildings with stuff oh my god they're
like breaking on the door let's go up
and then fill it in do we have any
blocks now we don't have any blocks so
oh my god this isn't top floor and
there's nothing here
there's nothing here where are you
Oh top floor no it ups nothing there
wait wait wait can we get to this wait
look over there what what what what up
to this level what we can make it to
that building well maybe uh okay you
first
but um what building oh I guess I could
make that yeah yep there we go
easy Bob where are you Laurie boxes oh
no but I'll call hey where are you guys
Laurie
we rarely jump to another goal no Morea
uh no um Rick Rick can I be Glenn I like
Glenn blends good get okay
sure and not because I'm Asian but you
know Glenn yeah right Bob
how are you uh I don't know any other
characters so I guess I'm so Lori you
still haven't watched the show nope oh
god yeah I get on that it's great show
would you get there's the chest we go
free diamonds and 5-iron but we don't
have that chest so we can't make
anything with that's our next goal well
boy does not Jess what's this where well
I got steak
what the hell Ari I'm jumping to Dean we
make this hop to the other bill flower
here I made it I made it I mean I know I
am going to the next building hop the
ball make it oh I don't know sorry do
Laura here Laura I'm doing it for Laura
I found it just yes yes just diamond
chestplate oh yeah
I felt it really it's like a parkour
episode already it is isn't it this is
walking parkour I'm going over to the
next step the next building where you
guys I'm gamma no I felt like a god mode
for some mysterious reason oh that's why
you're surviving everything open huh not
cheating JA cheating cheating on all
that yeah whatever where do we go oh no
we're just trying to escape the city but
we need supplies before we can move on
we can't escape the city though yeah
there's a there's an outside of the city
okay did you guys get this chest what
chest oh yes haha where's I'm [ __ ]
it see more like I'm in another building
don't even try to fall Oh God we're
starting which is building I don't know
look for my nametag
I can't see your nametag well that sucks
for you it does it really does it hurts
my feelings bro there's my phenols all
of them feels right in the feels
I'd like my favorite meme of the past
year like I love the feels thing in the
feels bro yeah aah zombies No hey
where's what we could we could have
saved him I mean in our with zombies oh
there we go we are they ha ha
there's body I mean God mode disabled no
no [ __ ] oh no ok I'm ok
ok ok I'm gonna come to you nah
that didn't last long at all
oh god this rings oh oh my god it's
raining zombies it's doing exactly what
you said oh goodness gracious luck
oh my support is broken oh man this is
horrifying this is a hair leave look
don't push me off
mmm okay I made it tomorrow haha oh
we're diesel haha diamond sword
enchanted book oh yeah where'd you guys
go oh man I found the mother lode oh hey
girl give me like the chest plate or
something then no how about you know
something how about you go I'm gonna
give this to Laura I'm Rick
I need like a gun hey look at anvil what
the oh I get it
oh I get it oh so I take the sword I put
this book here and boom oh I don't have
the experience for that Oh balls
Oh how'd you guys get over there we
jumped I got this look out
me and my diamond sward will protect us
ha ha ha
okay I'll just sit here neat steak you
do that on the hot oh they're getting
closer
ah they're overrunning us no no Oh
where'd you go you dead
Lori yes Lori no oh that's actually sad
cuz we shouldn't do
Lori's find Louis wait everybody oh man
oh alright so we need to carry on are we
about to die I need health this building
oh here here here wait i I have I have
steak please yes there oh thank I made
you steak mmm cuz I'm such a Goods
mmm mmm sheriff yes wait you're Rick now
Oh Chad me Rick I thought I was rig are
you Rick Oh Who am I oh yeah I'm Glenn
uh-huh help me I'm on the ground Urkel
or we just got in a complete circle
yeah wait that's our starting array over
there really yeah
I thought we came from that way
nope we have not gone far God some of
them
hey no cursing in this what is a PG
rated drunk minecraft really what yeah
since when since shut up and [ __ ] your
mother
that's 100 so burn I know I'm the king
maybe I should get some aloe vera for
the burn mark ahaha what [ __ ] was that
Bob what was that Bob Bobby always walk
but what was for that's quick
Todd I know it was like a zombie who's
that you what ok carrying on I'm very
creeped out now don't know what that was
where are you guys why I don't know sir
'cold up we apparently started in I'm
all alone here we need to venture out of
the city guys guys guys what why to
regroup oh I see you I see a road sign
what does it say ah actually it's
actually there's got layers missing so
actually says oh I'm not gonna read out
that's it says I'm Susan troll I've new
substance we must be French
I am French all right where's Bob we've
lost Laurie there's a lot of over here
that's must be a good sign right
Laury Laury Laury Laury Laury goo or
ghastly go oh no whatever that gerbil
was must have taken Laurie I guess it's
just you and me Phil let's go Oh God
we'll make it we'll go my oh my oh my
wooden wooden shovel dude yeah yeah feel
like some was Gamgee oh this you've got
the really epic sword that just got
frying pan yeah good job
well the frying pan can do a lot of damn
oh my god we're surrounded run run
Amy oh there is oh did your microphone
caught goddamn head
by this piece of [ __ ] head seen it wait
over here over here I see hills and
mountains woo kittens we're all out of
the city you've got zombies on your ass
no idea where the hell you guys are Bob
you're on your own
oh we had to abandon you because it was
getting kind of day there's a zombie
pigman hate it I made it yeah their head
that way head towards the lava and then
turn left
we made it I keep here we go now what
how'd you get there Bob what the damn
you're quick Bob you're quick yeah
definitely did that say oh honey all on
my own yeah okay all right yeah this is
definitely hell that we're in Oh sing
all the characters that died on the
walking dead came here not that anyone
has died no one no one's died no one's
died right yeah no one Soilers anyway
gonna show I'm going up to the top of
this mountain yep nah
oh those you I thought don't know Bobby
oh you wasn't major this is on me try to
get my diamond whatever oh ah oh sorry
huh I'm trying to hit the zombies you
look just say this but there's just more
hills this way damn it there's got to be
something a refuge in this place of
destruction and desolation oh wow
oh Jesus Christ John Jesus we realize
there are so many zombies out here
how would she out cheo cheo John this is
not a good thing I don't think this is
where we were supposed to me holy balls
so the call just running I've always
wired oh he'll get overrun by slow
zombies but this is a prime example of
how it I found something I found
something but I had to run past it what
where I'm going on something that's
inside but if I if I jump into it I'll
die I found wood in wood where did you
go I went on top of fun that's not one
of the big ones yeah there's wood here
we need wood I see you I'll lead you to
where the safe zone is we don't care the
same says it's real it's a myth man I
got you Bob I found like a prison thing
no you didn't see so it's part of the
script in the story so we did good
it's part of the what oh no the person
aware said always witty where's it
where's this way this way this way that
one where all the zombies are but it's
okay we feel good yeah good all right
back away
this way down into the cabin thing good
thing we got this professional
minecrafter here oh god you owe me this
is why I found I found it abandoned
mineshaft in than ever
oh good up let's find a tunnel and wall
ourselves soon the little leaves the
hell away from the zombies here I got
this oh here we go here we go ready is
boop-boo-boo-boop gun we're super so
yeah oh yeah that's his stuff huh
I just fight oh my god why oh oh reopen
the tunnel run away no we got this is
our home we have to fight for it
Oh screw it okay we're okay we're okay
I'll take care of the spider and more
zombie hey go hit me where you hitting
me
no Bob you bastard you won't win
pick one did it and you said it was fine
and I read it and it's not fine well I
mean there was no zombies coming from
that direction
well let's wall this one off okay kill
the zombie he's gonna even you kill
those ambience wall this up whatever
this is I don't know what that is is
nothing back it back get back
no I can't wall it up there's too many I
have to blow you in there Bob oh oh you
were there too oh yeah well I'm safe
I'm in oh we're so dead oh oh wait I'm
surviving okay I'm okay I'm okay okay oh
you guys still alive or did you die you
both die die damn you both die die I'm
walking my soldiers in with a group of
zombies what the hell were you thinking
well I'm here and that's all that
matters yeah wah wah wah wah wah
I was just glitched I was floating in
the space and then there was a stuff
yeah hey I'm back
hey what I wait oh I didn't hate you I
swear wait that's my stuff man that's my
stuff oh wait some of this is here stuff
yeah well some of it's mine too though I
mean I had you didn't have two sets of
leather armor did you yes cuz I'm just
not awesome yeah it seemed about right I
believe that here you can have your
diamonds and your iron and there are no
swords in here yeah if there's a stick
or anything I've got the diamond sword
so I guess you guys I had sticks though
I thought I don't have any sticks zombie
I need that ambulance takes in a
crafting table oh my god budget tech
there are a lot of them rushing
bat-o-matic I can't kill them fast
enough no oh my dog no no I'm a liar
here water fall off I'm alive I I you
bastard you son of a [ __ ] hey you did
that to me zombie can we have your
Marvel here perhaps a of a crafting
table I need a crafting table you guys
we have a wood here hang on let me make
a crafting table in the stick couple of
sticks then we can be awesome hey here
we go Boop and sticks you said boots
sticks sticks who unwalled this ah
zombie did it
alright I'm believing a chest high wall
that way we can still hit him oh god
they're coming
Dobby we need an anvil we need an Advil
man yeah this is exactly what I mean
like people don't realize it even though
they're slow if there's a lot of them
you're kind of boned yeah ah there's an
anvil okay watch this water this guy's
watch this guy boom smite for August hey
what did you combine that with just did
I got a book that was like a giant a
sword of some kind may prepare a name
I'm gonna call it I didn't name mine
damn
Luc's lioness saber you know I need 7 XP
to rename it to Luke's lightsaber no no
no get back mark pick it up dick I
didn't do anything what oh here
damn I could've sworn that was you I
tried it didn't work she felt good
seriously does anyone have iron or
somethin come on now Lori you don't have
all leather armor and a wood pickaxe
it's got about half life left on it I
gave you one iron horde or someone Zeus
would take that wood oh [ __ ] I have a
master sword what no what what Oh
breaking 10 sharp this for knock back
three fire aspect to last out my legends
suck it Dix how is that fair that one
that it's cuz you guys were sharing
anything okay what
no it makes it mean well not sharing I
shared it with you you gave me stuff
that is capable of assembling nothing I
at least as you would I'm in and ironing
it I don't soul edge like bullets baby
barf or pods eggs I got blood the blood
letter kit what no Beast has resisted
its power nor sorted its motion is that
a Scottish accent I don't know what that
was to be perfectly honest y'all gotta
pick like a mix of French in Japanese I
think it's Frost hunger Ruby stirs ever
resisted its power
no suspected its voracious hunger oh my
god I opened up the door
oh god I don't know
we're gonna hit you chipper with the
Olsens I got it I got it I got this I
got this I got this
oh god I'm lagging okay I'm okay all
right yeah we're okay zombie - all right
let's make a run for it go carry on
we're going forward hey there's a chest
here oh god I hit the pig man Oh Bob you
happy with your save anyone swing my
sword
Gilly screams I found a map you guys
want a map I want them on how the
spiders fun I have this map you I got it
Willy
I'm not the keeper I got to don't cry no
more oh okay so this is a blank map so
we should head this way well yeah it's a
blank map you don't have minecraft works
Hey look stairs where oh yeah let's
follow the stairs this doesn't seem like
a trap Willy - I will be on points no
one hit me god damn it Bob
I'm not even clicking you just run away
you think maybe Phil that it was the
zombies that hit you maybe oh no oh oh
bit okay you know what Bob is it hit me
from behind so I found a bunch of love
oh hello hey Mae cavern full of his
final thing slice was awesome yes I'm
gonna collect some wood well we're here
like this is a very weird wool world
that we got loaded up here I'm very
confused but it's marked it I just axe
you in the face no can I ask you a
question hey that's my line ah
Leela well yeah that is your line isn't
it yeah it is axe Zuko smelling those
max oh my god that is a lot of zombies
oh gosh guys guys rise rise ah [ __ ]
[ __ ] you heard me
guys guys you son of a [ __ ] Oh goomy no
Phil Phil kill this lovable IMing ah I'm
what we're back at spawn
Oh what's my fault it was you killed me
no but you should have seen it at the
end of an era
what damn it we did so well I know
ourselves well we got ten minutes left
so let's continue in another direction
wait where are you guys yes mine oh
there's nothing in this chest oh damn it
hey I found a diamond chestplate where
would it mine
no it's on my chest ha ha my boy migrant
oh hey I'm a big pile of stuff that I
think belongs to one of you guys oh
really
we'll get back to the spawn mmm how do I
get back to the so shot time I'll take
Oh who's that a guy heard a gasp wait I
got this Hey Oh God where is it where is
it where is it
accreditation I'm gonna go in this house
and take a shot that has my stuff please
mark can I have not mark what oh my god
Jojo be bob bobbi's girls fall and
wrinkle blocker uh I don't know how
Tommy has to get me back to the spot I
don't know how to get back to this you
don't know give me the swords that's one
that I'm right next to you
Hey Oh can I have my stuff back can you
hear that I didn't know you were down
here I thought I was alone shut up I
went I went back just as a gas big hit
us yeah well your barber stuff okay I I
I'm pretty much at the armor I had
before so I uh
yeah me too I'm uh yeah totally in my
original armor mark no one likes you
you've just arrived in your pink pink
outfit pink or this pink that's like
everything gin chanted it's pretty pink
it's enchanted I'm literally pretty pink
you taking the door with me hey there's
another downstairs here stairway down
what
I'm getting a airway to hell steer Wade
hell it's so much less inspiring so
alright more mine and more area fine
whoa hello-o and Dwight the fools clean
area to dry your food yeah Oh what it is
their work in the darkness you don't
know what it is they woke in the
darkness I've been practicing my extra
deep voice let me carry your extra deep
mode I've been practicing my extra deep
mode what do you think of this voice
here oh it's is it good I've ha ha ha oh
I got you I got you hot what did you
think I was going [ __ ] ha ha I didn't
know I didn't turn around
hey we're okay Carrie are the effective
uh water dyed it wrong
Rose there's downstairs downstairs why
are we still going town this seems like
a good idea this is this is we're going
the last time the last time we did this
everything started exploding I only one
hang on I could yeah sweet Jesus I was
writing my nuts diamond pick to the to
the nards I would pick to the balls dude
I guess we were finally be home man and
I get this uh dogs stick around it ah
God laughing at me I didn't do anything
what the hell did you do I don't know
oh jesus this lava everywhere this bad
ah poor zombies yeah no no I'm
surrounded I'm helping I also really
noticed that always say I have go nearly
two full stacks of zombie flesh hello
good baby song he's we've closed yeah
have you i wanted i XX yeah alright i
have noticed it over the time that I've
done Let's Plays my voice has really
kind of changed a lot and especially my
scream has become very more raps fine
yeah ah got the
rumble in the back oh all right so where
we got a cold so we're going into the
laggy caverns all I see are upstairs no
downstairs we're taking the hobbits to
Isengard are you getting Delft
Rory I am Gondo hi I'm Kendall the white
so don't [ __ ] my chaps we're doing our
own thing hahaha oh god what the hell is
this what the hell is what all that it
was a black skeleton with a sword Jesus
I never seen that before I don't know
what that was was that uh-huh
oh man I'm scared well are those things
I think are you sure things got weird
real quick
Oh God kind of look like the wither but
you know just mark you told me you organ
we're gonna play Minecraft I expected
happy fun times not with your [ __ ]
indie survival horror game ah usually
with drunk minecraft it is you a lot
less involved in this but woah oh oh
like on your grand bench
okay this is we just did this was a
mistake
let's go there's whoa whoa what happened
I just happen for anyone else I thought
oh wait what just happened I got it all
and holy crap why why like they're like
Endor skeletons they're Weaver Weaver
skeletons mom are there's a thing oh I'm
sorry did I kill you
I'm so sorry don't pick up his stuff
he'll get away ah ah
Jesus I've never seen wither I've never
encountered the wither in normal
minecraft so I have no idea why really
yeah well I mean I hardly ever played
normal why minecraft in yeah oh my gosh
my hell no these were in my hello this
block anyone elses hell that kind of
stuff but I've not actually mine was
okay what's that about I don't know
changed there's a bunch of them down
here where hey wait but wait got a wall
I'm off look they can't get underneath
like that bit wait why is there oh yeah
they're too tall what is that what's
that loading
our dollar with her Oh does that mean
that means means some ways there's a
wither ball Wow
Rhonda why do we keep saying these
things that we haven't encountered and
that all got it sir why are you seeing
this what the hell
it's a wither la wither skeleton but I
had it I had it once that's good enough
you realize that thing will actually
just destroy work art no matter what
you're doing no I got it I got this is
taken care of I'm a baller I'm a baller
boom hit it Jesus jeez this white white
snow this way out this way this way this
way okay okay
that's not you oh come on we'll get out
we'll go hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
what aa skeleton this way this way uh
chest up someone sword dude both of you
have swords I have a sword okay I got a
sword eyes a very good sword okay there
we'll check again
yes any extra pieces of armor oh I know
not you're on your Oh oh I found a new
bit we haven't gone to you before really
okay
this is Neal I need food I'll eat this
zombie flesh oh I got potatoes where'd I
get potatoes potatoes I uh they're a
rare drop from zombies ah oh god
potatoes not give much food hey I mean
probably have to cook them
oh yeah baked potatoes and all that what
is it war what the hell is this what ha
ha ha what is this I don't know whoops
whoa that's growl you're placing grab a
place gravel if I place wood that'll be
good right yeah yeah in lava wood in
lava it looks like a style it's not
gonna be fine it's gonna catch on fire
alright here we go I'm gonna just loop
up around this thing oh I see the wither
the withers health bar keeps popping up
at random times I'm very scared ah ah
no uh-uh I can't nah-ah
um okay I guess yeah is the final
showdown we have to face it here and now
oh this is as good a arena for the final
battle as possible
ah keep going to the lava Oh bollocks
I got it ah I can't even get to it I
cannot get to it it's just shooting
everything at me i I can't I'm dead god
damn it all this like ant I can't do
anything to it alright I'm abandoning
that venture and I'm gonna go drink more
and just have think of kittens and
babies oh man I don't want me to oh my
god I'm in TV back welcome back to hell
if I can just get past here I could get
my sword and then I can get my sword I
can hit him and then if I hit him then
maybe I can kill him and if I kill him
maybe people will like me no no no oh oh
oh
you killed it like a ball ah what oh
yeah Wow oh yeah another one there's
another wither so weird
I killed him I have no equipment that's
it I hear back with that sword and
that's all you get ah uh what you just
what you just give me a sword
I hope oh you got a full armor oh good
for you that will come in handy for when
we end the episode in 30 seconds oh I
didn't realize this big hole was here
there was not that is new alright I'm
going outside screw this I'm good it was
it was better with the zombies and
what's going on down here this is just
creepy
ah [ __ ] skeleton nah alright actually
we are all at a time
oh no um yep so sorry it's just sorting
ya know
the adventure has been happening geez
I'm not exist adventure ah [ __ ]
wither skeleton get out of here
ha ah can't climb to hit me so hard ah
what the [ __ ] dude I'm trying to close
me you winter skeletons
hey there's a house okay all right I'm
out of here I'm out of here
i matter [ __ ] this and [ __ ] everything
alright we are all at a time so ah [ __ ]
I'm in the hole again REI meaning listen
though so thank you everybody so much
for watching hope you enjoyed it and
remember to subscribe to fire UK's
channel links in the description and in
the annotation so thank you again
everybody for watching and as always
we'll see you in the next video bye bye
power the hell's s okay so give this a
try they're gonna say hi and I'm gonna
dodge them just like a boss
we're save up [ __ ] cows dogs dog [ __ ]
quick save